There is gas in this video I am going to talk about
another question from IIT JAM
Biotechnology 2016 and this question is
on chemistry organic chemistry so every they give a
compound and there given reagent further
sodium methoxide and ethanol and no god which
wise of these product wood  b d
appropriate product of this particular
reaction in order to solve this kid of
question you have to have clear understanding
of e2 elimination reaction but
today n rule of thumb they can
say date of reagent chlorine and n hydrogen around this would be
eliminator so if  You
just draw d hydrogen both is
above d plane
you below d plane
elimination reaction can take place
you possible
conditions from where illumination can happen
one and you no elimination bld take place from which of this
think so every d hydrogen is above
d place and if  They talk
about this 0.2 every they have one hydrogen which is below
d plane so d hydrogen date is below d
plane wood b
eliminator along with this chlorine and d
double band wood b formed in this condition in this
position don't get
confused of a  And C Because
C Also Everything Is Quite Similar Apart
From These Methyl Group Position And It Is
Above D Plane But In D Substance It Was
Actually Below D Plane So Correct Option
Is A Not C You Enjoy D Video And This
Type Of Question Is Very  Important this
type of question repeated two times consecutively
in 2016 and 2015 so you enjoyed this
video please like and
subscribe thank you